the Caribbean Sea off the coast of
Central America the Belize Barrier Reef
stretches more than 250 kilometers and
is the second largest reef system in the
world
it's one of the earth's most diverse
ecosystems and now home to a relative
newcomer native to the water is off Asia
and Australia lionfish are breeding
rapidly in the Caribbean Sea and
according to marine biologist Jennifer
Chapman are threatening the fragile
ecological balance there
lionfish have voracious appetites they
basically are indiscriminate feeders
they will just eat anything they come
across the knock-on effects to the rest
of the coral reef just enormous what is
now regarded as an infestation started
in Florida in the 80s when a handful of
lionfish kept in aquariums ended up in
the sea
since then the insatiable predators have
been eating their way through their host
waters they were first spotted off
Belize six years ago an encounter with a
lionfish can be a painful experience as
they're pretty fins hide venomous spines
with their NGO blue ventures Chapman is
trying to convince fishermen not to be
afraid of the lionfish here in Santa Nia
in northern Belize she informs the
locals that the fish could be an
alternative to mussel and lobster and
shows them that the spines can be cut
off can you see any spines here these
fishermen are pretty pragmatic imagine
what would happen if we couldn't catch
the lionfish they'd end up taking over
our fishing territory increasing numbers
of fishermen are beginning to see the
lionfish not only as a threat but also
as an opportunity nevertheless there
still needs to be a consumer demand for
the fish in the village of Santa Nia
lionfish has long featured on the menus
in públicos restaurant a fillet of fish
with rice beans and cabbage is an old
favorite and more than 100 dishes are
served each week Jennifer Chapman's blue
ventures wants to see the same success
all across Belize it's believed to be
impossible to completely clear the
Caribbean of lionfish but it may finally
have met its first real enemy man